last time we talked about how these kind
of uh networks and image generation
systems work but there are different
kinds aren't there there are there's
daily two there's Imogen there's stable
diffusion and I didn't talk about in the
last video because they are for the sake
of understanding diffusion models in
general essentially the same but
actually they are quite different
underneath right and it comes down to
you know the resolution exactly where
you do the embeddings
um how you do the embeddings how you
structure your network and so on and so
forth right so and in fact actually in
stable diffusion's case it comes down to
where you do the diffusion as well
um so let's look we'll look at the
stable diffusion code because I've got
access to that right and um and we'll go
into it in quite some detail I think
will be quite interesting um I've really
enjoyed using it because first of all
it's giving me a better understanding of
how it works and also you can do some
pretty cool stuff by messing about down
there and say well what if I gave it a
frog but also a snake right and the
answer is you get a frog snake
um
yeah exactly snake giraffe was the stuff
of nightmares
there were questions about ethics there
were questions about how these are
trained maybe we deal with them another
time um let's talk about how they work
so Dali 2 is perhaps at the moment the
biggest one but it's being actually I
think rapidly overtaken by stable
diffusion primarily because stable
diffusion is more available to people
right I can download the code and run it
of stable diffusion darly you access
fire an API and you say I would like an
image please and it gives you something
back
um if you don't have any interest in the
code then sure just use the API but if
for example like me you might be
interested in what the applications for
generating images in your area of
research like plants or medical imaging
maybe I want the access to the code and
I can train up the network myself right
so Darley
Builds on a lot of studies from open AI
it builds on a lot of stuff that they've
already done right the first one is
something called clip embeddings clip
embeddings are the way of taking your
text tokens and turning them into some
meaningful numbers right and remember
we're going through a Transformer so
we're not just saying well look the word
the word the is a five and the word
football is a 17. what we're doing is
we're taking the whole sentence we're
doing a lot of cross attention and
saying this is the overall meaning of a
sentence reflected numerically so you
get some context yeah that's the idea
and clip is trained with image and text
pairs so you put in an image you put in
the text that describes that image and
what you try and do is align those two
embeddings so they kind of make sense
and that way you've got a kind of
semantically meaningful text embedding
so it's a bit like a supervised data set
of some sort it is yeah it's it's sort
of it is a supervised data set it's
trained using a contrastive loss which
is what this CL stands for and the idea
is that basically you want to try and
make embeddings of an image and its text
description very very similar and the
embeddings of an image with a different
text description very very different
right in not in a dissimilar way to how
we when we were doing the face ID stuff
we're trying to put my face near
previous shots of my face so you can
unlock a phone all right I'll knock a
phone of your face uh that was the one
if you want to unlock a face with your
phone so you've got a clip embedding
this is for text embedding you also have
various other things that works in Dali
and I'm going to sort of simplify it
slightly you put in an image which I
think is at 64 by 64 pixels you put in a
noise image at 64 by 64 right you put in
your time you put in your clip text
embeddings and you also put them into
the network like we described in the
previous video you have a giant unit
structure that produces an estimate for
the noise and you look and you Loop now
that produces a a not bad image but only
at 64 by 64 pixels this process of
randomly producing noise checking with
its work subtracting it producing this
takes a long time at high resolution and
the next sort of network you would need
would be astronomically big so to make
that easier we only run at a 64 by 64.
now of course how do we then
make that nice right because just dial
E2 outputs one k by 1K images the answer
is we put and we have another Network
that does the same thing but this time
its job is to up sample so you basically
put in a noisy 64 by 64 and say output
me with 256 version right and and so on
so forth so you you put this through I
think two levels of up sampling to go
from 64 to 256. to 1024. we'll be part
of my dumb question yeah are we finally
at the point where we can say in hands
you know what we are yeah
um except except and it will work
exactly like it does in a TV where it
will just make up nonsense and they'll
call it a win uh it works pretty well
Imogen Google's version works in a very
similar way you have a you have a
network that's trained to denoise and
generate 64 by 64 images Guided by text
and then you have two up sampling
networks that go up to 1024. stable
diffusion does its diffusion process
sort of in this bit in some sense you
have what we call an autoencoder which
takes some noise
and turns it into a lower resolution but
detailed representation you then do the
diffusion process this way
which denoises that latent space and
then you have the other side of the
autoencoder which expands it back out
into an image so this is a different way
of doing it and the advantage is that
this is much lower resolution than this
and they call it stable diffusion
there's an argument that is slightly
more stable I don't know to what extent
that's true there are some differences
in the way that these produce images but
in all other regards basically it's the
same kind of process you're still doing
guidance from text you're still putting
in T it's just that you're now doing it
in this latent space instead of in the
full image space think of it like like
you put it through a zip right and you
can press it down and then you do all
the diffusion in that space and then at
the end you expand it back out again
right that's the idea and actually the
auto encoder is very very good right you
can take an image you can compress it
right down and it'll still produce much
the same image again let's dive into the
code and have a look right so I'm in
Google collab now for those who don't
know Google collab is a sort of jupyter
notebook style environment that allows
you to access also Google's gpus for
running you know machine learning things
now I don't tend to use Google collab
generally because a lot of our processes
last longer than you really meant to use
it for but for this it's excellent right
so I've got this code from um a guy
called Jonathan Whitaker which I then
repurpose and done my own stuff with it
and I've been messing about so thanks
very much to him for that but I've taken
it and I've played around I've changed
the resolution I've I've toyed around
with a lot of stuff and what I wanted to
do was talk through some of these lines
of code so you can see what it is that
it's doing it's the same exact process I
just described
um it's just a few lines of code to do
it now obviously there's a lot of deep
networks and stuff going on behind the
scenes but they end up getting extracted
away abstracted away in function calls
and so it becomes very straightforward
okay I've imported all my libraries
already and then what we've got here is
one go we're going to have our text
prompt and what we're going to do is
take that text prompt and produce an
image right so we have various things
like we want it to be 512 pixels tall
768 pixels wide we're going to run 50
steps of inference and then a few other
things that we can talk about in a
moment like for example we're going to
seed it with the number four now why why
four because I I don't know I picked it
at random I can see I can see it at 77
if you like this allows us to run the
exact same code again and produce the
exact same image another time if we just
used a random seed if you got to an
image you liked you accidentally get rid
of it you never get it back right so
um but if you change this number you get
entirely different images because the
noise that you start with is entirely
different right so let's put in a prompt
well what should we do fogs on stilts I
think we need to do frogs on stilts
I I mean this may not work I don't you
know anything else you want to add like
in you know in a park or just just focus
on stilts what about on a stage
okay focus on stills on a stage at the
theater right yeah now
the first thing we have to do is we have
to embed this uh into some kind of
usable space in which the machine
learning can work so what we do is we
tokenize this is the function that
tokenizes the text input and basically
turns it into a numerical code for each
word and then that goes into the text
encoder which is our clip embeddings so
that's the bit where it sort of works
out the context yeah that's the
Transformer that goes well okay this
this one kind of goes with this word and
then this means they share weights and
so on and then you go through the
transform and you end up with
essentially to us meaningless numbers
put to there to this semantic
information on the meaning of the
sentence right
we also because if you remember we put
it through the network twice one with
the text embeddings and one without so
we also have to produce a dummy text
embedding with nothing in it right and
that's what this unconditioned input is
then we're going to text encoder
unconditioned embeddings and we get
two text embeddings one of which is
unconditioned and one of which is
conditioned right so this one has fogs
on stilts this one is just sort of blank
now we need to set our schedule remember
you can choose a scheduler that produces
different amounts of noise at each time
step right and and which one you use
will depend on to an extent the kind of
images you want out but also how you've
trained the network we're going to be
using the standard one that came with
stable diffusion and I'm going to run
for 50 time steps so what this will do
is distribute the amount of noise it
adds from 0 to 50. right so when I say
50 it's going to produce the maximum
amount of noise and when I say one it's
going to produce a tiny amount of noise
right that's the idea and then
we're going to actually produce our
latent noise that we're going to be
diffusing so we create a random array of
numbers right of the right size and
we're going to call these latents and
we're going to stick them on the
graphics card and then we're going to do
some scaling to our latents as well
because the the scales of some of these
different parts of a network are
different so you have to move them in
and out and then we're nearly done right
this is our Loop so how does the loop
work well the first thing we do is we
calculate the noise to be added at this
particular iterations we're going
through all the different time steps and
we're going to add a different amount of
noise we're going to add this noise to
our latent space right so basically
we're noising up the image here now
remember this is a this is a an embedded
version of this image but it is noised
then we're going to predict the noise
with our unit so that is saying how much
noise do you think was in this image
such that we can get back to the
original image bearing in mind this text
and then we can do our actual classifier
free guidance right so what we're going
to do is we're going to take our noise
prediction with text and our noise
prediction without text we're going to
calculate the difference and amplify it
and then we're going to work out what
our official noise prediction is and
then finally we're going to then use
that noise prediction to calculate a
slightly less noise version of the image
which is what this line does here and
we're going to repeat this process right
so we repeat the process we calculate
the new noise at the next time step we
predict it we subtract it away and add a
bit more noise and we repeat this
process and the idea is that over 50
iterations we go from fully noise to
some reasonable image
should we see okay so let's run at this
resolution I'm pushing the amount of
image size I can get in on this graphics
card so this is running on your graphics
card here no this is running on Google's
graphics card uh over at Google right
could you be somewhere in London can I
owe you another eight pounds for this uh
and we can give me eight pounds no this
is covered under the original eight
pounds per month
but hopefully this won't take a month to
record so we're choosing 50 iterations
for this and because that's a decent
amount right you'll notice that if you
don't do enough iterations you're trying
to move the noise too quickly it becomes
a bit unstable doesn't produce nice
results
of course I've not I've not done this
before I don't know what the use of the
results will be will it be frogs and
stilts will it be bits of wood next to a
fog will it be something different
because it's failed horribly uh let's
see
actually that's not bad no I think
that's uh that is pretty impressive now
there's a weird leg coming out of this
fog here but I would I would say that is
a comparatively successful attempt this
was produced from a noisy image
so what we can do is we can change the
noise seed so we can say you know 128
and what that will do is create a
completely different noise which will
probably lead to a tightly different
image right I mean it's still the same
text prompt so it's still guided in the
same way but this allows us to produce
sit near infinite numbers basically of
fogs on stills if that's your thing
right it is my thing actually yeah I've
got quite into producing like cityscape
futuristic cityscapes I think that's
where I I spend most of my time on this
I mean that's gone a bit wrong but
actually still not bad it looks like a
kind of stage
um they're just a bit not foggy
although yeah yeah all right all right
okay so anyway we could spend let's say
another 20 30 minutes producing fogs on
stilts
um but yeah so what you could there's
loads of cool stuff you can do
presumably you could just uh automate
that so it just kept giving you loads
yeah and in fact I've done that right so
for example I created some nice pictures
of dystopian abandoned futuristic cities
with over plants right and then I just
put them in a for Loop and just produce
200 of them so I can pick the nice ones
for example in here
I've just got a bunch of awesome looking
City Vistas overgrown plants they all
look really really good right I'm quite
pleased I mean I've got no use for this
but it's quite fun and the other thing
is because you can do image to image
guidance right so what you do is you
take an image that's your guide image
you nearly noise it all the way and then
you reconstruct right so the noise is
somewhat not come from a random place
then you can get an image that sort of
bears some Reflections you can say well
I want a building over here and a tree
over here so I'll draw them in and then
I'll produce this and it will bear the
same have the same shapes and stuff so
you can control this process even if you
basically like me have absolutely zero
artistic ability at all
um and to give you an example what I did
was uh so if I go down let me let me go
so this is a picture of my my colleague
rabbit by cute rabbit and what I did was
I embedded this added noise but not
totally noise to remove the image and
when I reconstructed it with the text a
wooden carving of a rabbit eating a leaf
highly detailed 4K Artisan I don't know
if you are sound where it does anything
I just thought it'd be fun it's trending
on Art station I see a lot of that put
on the end of things does that make a
difference I don't know anyway and it
produces a wooden carving of a rabbit
right and if you look at the original
image versus this image some things have
changed sure but the shape is roughly
the same right so it has guided this
process using the original image and
that's how image to image works so if
you wanted to create an animation you
could create quite a simple animation of
a rabbit jumping about with no artistic
ability right I mean actually I was
struggling to do even that but and then
each frame you could then use this
process to produce it at the moment
there's no kind of temporal consistency
so you will see flickering right if you
ever see one of these videos someone's
produced online it'll look cool but
maybe not consistent and interesting
because each frame might subtly change
things
um but that's the idea right now you can
do loads of weird stuff right so this
mix guidance is one of my favorite
things here we have two text inputs and
what we're going to do is we're going to
embed both of them we're actually going
to guide the generation using the
midpoint of those two right so I'm going
to say okay I want a rabbit right and I
want a frog
and I want you to produce me a 50 50
rabbit frog right and what it will do is
it'll embed both of them and it will do
the exact same process it's just for now
its text prompt is halfway between these
two embeddings so you could potentially
come up with a system with sliders uh
you know
what's it to what amount of fog do you
want in this image right I mean um
um you know again not sure what the use
case is but it's quite cool here we go
so it only takes about I think I'm
training for 50 steps again so I'm
running it for 50 steps while this work
you can do loads of stuff so for example
you could generate an image and then you
could take half of it and try and
generate the other half to expand it
outwards and slowly grow your image to
make an even higher res one right if
you're limited by the resolution and
there's going to be a lot of people
playing around a lot of different ways
to use this I've already seen the
plugins for gimpin for um for Photoshop
and stuff
whatever it is it's a strange one we'll
put links to the code in the description
have a go you really need to register
for hugging face to get access to the
weights originally but then you can use
something like Google collab or your own
Hardware to generate pictures and people
are having a lot of fun there are
websites now where you can find cool
images and the prompts that we use to
generate them to give you some ideas so
there's lots of cool stuff to do and the
rabbit is the same shape rabbit there's
a bit more noise right and then we come
over here and we come over here
and we end up with just noise it looks
like nonsense and so the question for
the same amount of time to make one
sandwich but you've got two people doing
it so they make twice as many sandwiches
each time they make a sandwich same with
the computer we could either make the
computer processor faster or